[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en Pologne matteus moravieki a publié
une vidéo choc on y voit des images de
Marseille de Nanterre de Strasbourg ou
de Paris des images de pillage de
bâtiments feux de tir de mortier et ses
scènes de violence alternent avec des
scènes bucoliques tournées en Pologne
des familles dans un parc une enfant qui
s'achète une glace des jolies filles qui
se promènent dans les rues le message
est clair il fait bon vivre chez nous
pas comme en France
dans les pays connu pour leur passé
colonial le racisme culturel s'est
transformé en racisme institutionnel
l'architecture sociale construite par
cette mentalité est à l'origine des
événements qui ont commencé en France et
ce sont étendus à d'autres pays en peu
de temps
si demain vous attrapez votre gamin qui
descend dans la rue pour brûler des
véhicules de police ou des caillassiers
des pompiers ou pays des magasins la
méthode c'est quoi ces deux claques et
au lit deux claques et au lit c'est un
message adressé aux parents mais ne vous
y trompez pas c'est un message d'amour
aimer ses enfants c'est les cadrer c'est
les accompagner c'est aussi les punir ça
s'appelle l'éducation et ce serait pas
mal que des parents ne l'oublient pas
cette jeune fille de 18 ans vient
découper de quatre mois de prison ferme
elle vient de passer sa première nuit en
détention elle qui n'avait pas de casier
judiciaire mais qui a été arrêté dans un
magasin p é ce week-end j'ai fait ça
pour l'adrénaline reconnaît-elle à la
barre et elle regrette aujourd'hui mais
cela n'a pas suffi l'un de ses amis ne
comprend pas la sévérité de la peine il
y a aussi une responsabilité peut-être
Driss Galli de ce qui habite dans ces
quartiers
on a le droit aussi de le dire on a le
droit aussi de le dire la responsabilité
des parents la responsabilité de ce qui
casse de ceux qui saccage et on l'a vu
Olivier accepterais-tu de m'adopter
afin que moi je puisse porter ton nom
avec fierté comme mes deux petites sœurs
adorées Kenzo
[Musique]
oui
il faudrait qu'elle a la première
infraction on arrive à sanctionner
financièrement et facilement les
familles une sorte de tarif minimum dès
la première connerie une position
diverses accueillie la raison
et la raison il faut un responsable pour
ça non c'est quoi cette éducation il
faut plus de moyens plus d'outils pour
ces jeunes c'est pas que les parents
chaque année depuis plus de 300 ans des
hommes se battent à coup de pénis de
taureau séché au Nicaragua on les
appelle d'ailleurs les chilly lo et
regarder des images sont d'une rare
violente d'autant plus que les Verts
sont particulièrement longues et souples
un peu comme des serpents ou des fouets
les règles sont claires pourtant de ce
jeu on peut pas enfin on peut frapper
partout sauf en dessous de la ceinture
on ne peut pas en revanche pas de coup
de pénis non plus sur le visage ça c'est
interdit je le dis aujourd'hui chiche si
Monsieur Macron décide d'installer ce
texte de l'inscrire à l'ordre du jour on
peut le voter avant le 14 juillet la
gauche elle refuse de toucher au
portefeuille de ses parents mettre la
tête sous l'eau de ceux qui sont déjà au
fond du trou ça va pas nous aider maman
qui travaille en horaires décalé chez
Carrefour et qui n'est pas là au moment
où son enfant sort du collège il traîne
dans la rue elle est toute seule à
bosser pour essayer de remplir le frigo
je vous rappelle toutefois qu'un certain
nombre d'obligations vous incombent il
vous appartient de veiller au respect
par votre enfant des obligations et
interdictions qui lui sont imposés à
défaut une enquête pénale sera diligente
afin de vérifier si votre responsabilité
pénale personnelle peut être engagée
résultat du bac sont tombés ce matin
pour les candidats de métropole on note
un léger recul du nombre d'admis 84,9%
contre 86,1% l'année dernière
bien
c'est incroyable je m'attendais à ce que
je sois admis parce que je pense que
j'avais fait du bon travail dans les
épreuves mais la mention non je veux pas
parce que j'avais oublié qu'il y en
avait des mentions en fait
il y avait un petit dessin hier qui
circulait sur les réseaux sociaux vous
aviez quelqu'un qui met votre boutique
et votre magasin n'a pas été attaqué et
la personne disait non je suis libre
donc c'était mention bien pour Adam 12
ans qui donne le sourire à toute la
famille très content et fier de lui
récompense une année de travail voilà
donc voilà on est tous très content sort
ez les prix il y a comment
couper
comme un goûter j'aime quand tu parles
de ma vie comment couper
un projet
des cahiers calcinés d'établir des
chaises réduites ensemble ce matin
l'émotion est encore vivante devant
l'école élémentaire du bois de l'étang
entièrement brûlé la nuit de mercredi à
jeudi dernier Charlotte mère de famille
confie son désarroi au maire de la ville
moi ce qui m'a fait pleurer je me
permets c'est le soir quand il était 3h
du matin que j'étais en train de voir
l'école brûler je voyais les petits
manteaux accrochés au porte-manteaux
prendre feu et là je me suis dit quand
même donc aujourd'hui c'est vrai que
surtout ma fille le matin tous les
matins elle se lève elle me demande si
ça maternelle n'a pas cramé non c'est
manifs aussi personne ne le dit trop
mais c'est aussi la conséquence du covid
alors là franchement vous trouvez des
excuses là pour le coup c'est vous qui
trouvez des excuses des gens qui sont
pas des actes
ça n'a rien à voir avec le covid
[Musique]
et c'est mon petit doigt où tu vas hier
nous évoquions l'enquête sur la mort de
Naël nous avons pour cela utilisé le
travail de l'ONG index qui a tenté de
rendre le son de la vidéo plus audible
mais sans parvenir à une conclusion les
sous-titres que nous avons utilisés
donnés une version de l'IGPN nous nous
exclusions pour cette erreur auprès de
l'ONG et de tout noter les spectateurs
oui cette cagnotte est conforme aux
conditions d'utilisation de la
plateforme Goffin mi car elle n'est pas
dédiée à la défense juridique du
policier mis en examen pour meurtre mais
à sa famille en l'état il n'y a aucune
infraction nous assure une source
judiciaire la cagnotte n'affiche pas un
objet illicite et il n'y a pas d'indice
de détournement par rapport à cet objet
les réseaux sociaux jouent un rôle
considérable dans les mouvements des
derniers jours j'attends de ces
plateformes l'esprit de responsabilité